we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two david p we talked about ted
cruz recently on the show ted cruz
didn't like what I had to say about him
and he called then take a listen to this
David this is Senator Ted Cruz calling I
heard your segment today where you
reference me and you called me depraved
and degenerate right and that's fair you
have your opinion but I also heard you
say as you launched into that quote
about Roy Moore which well yeah it's
strategic but whatever I mean I have a
daughter so yeah it's gross but you said
that you could hear my unique and
distinctive voice in your head you know
you had an opportunity to really
impersonate me with that juicy quote and
you didn't take advantage the thing is I
found exactly the way I look all you got
to do is look at me and you can hear my
voice in your head echoing echoing
echoing like a leprechaun in a cave full
of helium helium yeah pretty good so
we've had some big names callin lately
we had Bill Clinton Collins had Cruz has
called in a lot a lot of big names
listening to the show so that's uh
that's exciting for lack of a better
term pretty good he has the cadence down
I would say oh the cadence is almost
perfect and the voice is 90% air
it'sit's okay yeah the echo thing I
didn't like though on the bonus show
today Donald Trump has picked a ghost
hunter to be a federal judge Ohio sets a
new execution date after failing to find
an inmate's vein what a lovely evening
and UCLA players apologize for
shoplifting in China and thank the
president Donald Trump will tell you
about that on the bonus show the Jenga
tower has fallen meaning that you can
use coupon code gen go fifty eight for a
fifty eight percent discount off of
membership I have stuck to my word
Jenga fifty eight at david pakman.com
slash membership you can also access the
bonus show by becoming a five
dollar-a-month patron at patreon.com
David Pakman show we will speak to you
then